[Laughter]
just put the cut in there or you didn't
add the special effect yeah okay you
ready yes I am hi John Luke ruse
Slenderman is a new horror film out in
theaters this weekend and I went and saw
it with my buddy John Flickinger because
we tend to see movies like this together
and we love talking about them together
and I love making videos about this
together with you thank you Chris thank
you for that introduction I usually I'm
talked into seeing movies like this with
you I'm always laying a bed in the fetal
position and you forced me to do it and
then I cry I'm sorry okay
Slenderman is about some teenage girls
who summon Slenderman they watch a video
on the internet referred to as a website
video by Joey King the actress they all
watched a website video welcome to this
website video we're making
in which we talk about Slenderman I hope
that you enjoy watching it on this
website because we can't say the word
YouTube we cannot we cannot use YouTube
or else they probably would have in the
video but have they used YouTube in the
movie everyone would be dead on the
planet right movies like Slenderman make
me miss movies like bye-bye man or truth
or dare I'm very sorry because at least
those are slightly entertaining in a bad
way yeah this films just it's boring
yeah that's my biggest issue I think
with Slenderman is that like for the
I'll be honest with you like for the
first 20 minutes I was thinking this
could be worse this could be a lot worse
than it is and it's basically because
the film does have some creepy imagery
and some entertaining ideas like the
idea of sender man using FaceTime
basically to
come to these people's houses and you
said earlier that it looked like it was
shot on a gimbal slenderman just coming
through their house and you know that's
kind of an entertaining idea that the
actual video they watch on the website
that they go to it was kind of creepy
reminded me of the ring curse tape which
you know it was definitely tributing or
ripping off or paying homage to that
whatever you want to call it but then at
some point you realized that the film
only has creepy imagery
there's no characters there's no real
story there's no real narrative it
doesn't even really have a main
protagonist and then it just gets boring
yeah the movie does not know what it
wants to be and it I wanted a movie that
either focuses on slender man or the
insanity of these girls and their
obsession with Slender Man that could
have been a good movie either way this
one we can't make up its mind and much
like Slender Man
I like to scare teenage girls with
snapchat as well joke it's a joke I just
yeah I believed you yeah all right I
thought you were talking to follow the
flick pic on snapchat in regards to the
main characters it's these four teenage
girls and I felt like they they all went
missing in the order of most talented
Dilys talented yeah why couldn't the
least talented actress die first in the
film and it would have been a better
movie the young girl in the film from
from oculus who was I thought it was
amazing in oculus she's the first to go
missing and Joey King who is probably
the most known definitely the most known
out of all of them is you know kind of
at one point the main character and then
it's another girl who's the main
character and it switches so much the
acting here is for the most part awful
very panicky to save Lee's we have to
sacrifice this film needed more insane
moments it needed just not just because
I want to go to a movie and laugh at a
horror film that I find hilariously bad
it just needed more moments that went
for it our favorite scene I think in the
whole movie
is when the one girl and the boy that
they start making out and he gets he
gets kind of into it he gets and I was
like are they about to like have sex
right now in this movie and slender man
somehow infects him and his face starts
like going all over the place some tanks
we were squealing like little girls
it was like zooming in on his face and
it's just me anyways like this crazy
it's everything I wanted the rest the
way to be and that's what this movie
should have been because if you look at
what this movies based on it's based on
a free to download game from 2012 the
demo for this movie are like teenagers
or people just want to go and see a
scary movie with funny scenes and the
crazy stuff happening this movie took
itself way to serious absolutely it
should not have yeah and it's also way
too late like I feel like this has died
out like Slenderman is a thing there's
been talks about it there was a
horrifying real-life case with two girls
who attacked another girl because they
they believed in Slenderman and I just
feel like it's all it's maybe just it's
we're done with this like maybe move on
five years past it's due date like we're
done with Slenderman but Hollywood wants
to milk everything for all it's worth
and I just it seems like every five to
ten years Hollywood wants to make a
movie based around some urban legend
they actually made a movie called urban
legend with Jared Leto that was pretty
bad about a whole bunch of them yeah I
mean there were a few moments in the
movie that I thought were okay some
atmospheric building some great lighting
some sound effects this work that was
good and then like but it just that's
all it has it's a big movie where people
walk through corridors or hallways or
see creepy lights and maybe he's behind
you in the corner and then nothing
happens and when you do finally see him
he's a big CGI monster guy and tree man
you're right out of it the thing about
this film is it just borrows every trope
every cliche thing from every horror
film of the last five years and all
those things are bad because they're
based around teenage girls texting each
other or facetiming or snapchat and are
using the Internet to watch scary videos
and this wakes all those things but does
a worse job than every other movie that
already did them absolutely and it also
doesn't really follow its own rules
there's a lore that's set up for
Slenderman
at different points that and you never
really explore it like they go into the
woods and they're like we have to give
Slenderman something we love so we can
get our friend Katie back and they all
do it and then the one girl is stupid
and she peeks out of her blindfold and
then the Slenderman appears and I guess
whatever they tried to do didn't work
because maybe she peaked or whatever and
then towards the end of the movie mild
spoilers I guess if you're really
concerned one of the girls feels that
she needs to give herself to Slenderman
to solve all these problems
yeah so she approaches him and is like
take me and he goes basically like okay
and he and he just appears and comes
towards her and she screams and runs
away I'm like why are you in the woods
right now did you do this why are you
running you just literally said out loud
take me and now you're running away
because oh my god he's scarier looking
than I thought yeah she could have had
at least one heroic moment in the movie
and it still could even do that and the
wrap-up for the movie I thought was just
the most throw away like narration from
a character we've barely experienced and
it just ended and I was like alright
well they made a Slender Man movie I'm
so glad no this film need listen this
movie could have been made with a budget
of $25,000 out in the woods with some
flashlights it should have been on the
level of what they did the Blair Witch
it could it be this could be a fun found
footage movie yeah yeah it should have
been that if ever you were going to do
that this is the one because it's a POV
game with yeah it's white yeah it's a
perfect opportunity they could have made
a lot more money to they could have and
I don't know why that's that I'm
actually campaigning for a found footage
movie at this point either we need to
acquire the IP to this and make this
film Chris okay okay alright yeah
and we also need to acquire the rights
to YouTube so we don't have to say a
website video just a website video yeah
at the very least with a movie like this
I expect it to be maybe a little
frightening or just a little bit
suspenseful but it's just a bunch of
jump scares over and over again there's
a scene in the library where Joey King
is looking for a book because you know
she has to go to the library because
it's a horror movie with teenagers so
there's a library scene and she hears a
noise and she turns around and the
librarian just appears on a car
and it's like I just I couldn't stop
laughing it was everything that I wanted
for the rest of the movie I one of the
scenes like that and then this this
library scene goes on and on and and she
of course falls down and forgets how to
walk the girls are constantly falling in
the forest and forgetting how to run
without tripping and it's just every
horror movie cliche you could think of
when there when the girls are all
together what do they talk about the
boys they like it's just every cliche
over and over again they do watch porn
at one point in the beginning yeah that
did happen yeah and I was like that's
funny like that was sort of like a
little more realistic yeah do like have
some fun with this other than watching
camera shots of them texting on their
phone for 25% of the movie also here's a
thing that I noticed throughout the
movie the the main character sometimes
and then sometimes not the main
character
apparently she's really into track
because when they go out into the woods
to to give something up that they that
they love yeah the one girl's like I'm
surprised you're not giving one of your
money rewards up or one of your medals
and I was like what where's this
confrontation from and then later in the
movie they have another little
conversation where she's like aren't you
don't you have track practice why is
this a thing we've never even seen her
in track practice or her medals or her
awards like why is this a subplot
it's like a big deleted subplot that
they keep referencing and it could have
played out maybe there would have been a
scene at the end of the movie where she
runs away from Slenderman through the
woods and actually escapes but she falls
down all the time so why is she in track
she sucks
Slenderman just walking towards her and
she takes a rock and throws it and kills
capitate so yeah I would have liked that
a better ending I would have loved it
just take a fucking chains on cut the
tree - it's like easy lives in a tree or
something he sucks all of them into a
tree and then he just sits out there in
the woods I think that was the plot of
the Halloween earnest movie I don't
really feel like grading this movie
because like I don't really know what to
say
I'll give Slenderman like a D it had
like a couple scenes and I was like oh
you know whatever but then it doesn't do
anything and it just ends and it's a
long series of of nothing because
there's no characters really I mean it's
not like I go to these movies expecting
much it's just that sometimes I've seen
so many horror movies at this point that
I expect just a minimal amount of things
and this movie didn't really even go
much beyond just a few creepy parts this
I wouldn't expecting nothing and I got
less than that I honestly feel I was
this movie made me tired when I was
watching it I wanted to sleep yeah well
guys those are our thoughts on Slender
Man go check it out guys it's pretty
good yeah go see Slender Man it's my
recommendation mm-hmm is that you you go
see it
[Applause]
[Music]